Southwest Airlines is facing what its
own managers call an operational state
of emergency it's due to an unusually
high number of Southwest Boeing 737s
being taken out of service for
maintenance in a memo obtained by CBS
News the airline called for an
all-hands-on-deck and it warned that
maintenance employees could face
termination for on excused absences the
spike in out of service planes follows a
CBS News investigation in the mechanics
complaints of undue pressure to put
aircraft back in service faster Kris Van
Cleave has been all over this story it's
been a rough Presidents Day weekend for
Southwest Airlines since Friday the
carrier experienced more cancellations
and delays than any other US airline
about 100 flights were canceled for
maintenance reasons as the airline
struggles to keep up with an unusually
high number of aircraft taken out of
service for maintenance issues they
include the planes in yellow in these
pictures obtained by CBS News in all
more than 40 planes a day out of service
that's more than double the usual
average and about 5% of Southwest's
roughly 750 plane fleet it prompted
Friday's operational state of emergency
memo such a declaration is not
unprecedented but it is rare I think it
is an indication of problems
Jon gulia is a former member of the NTSB
this kind of stress in an operation is
not good it doesn't bode well for the
safety of the airline a dozen Southwest
mechanics tell us co-workers felt
emboldened to write up problems
following our CBS news investigation
earlier this month into allegations of
undue pressure on mechanics at Southwest
also last week Southwest had to check 22
engines to ensure the proper fuel pump
filter seals or a rings were installed
the operational state of emergency memo
came just days after senators Ed Markey
and Richard Blumenthal sent a letter to
the FAA seeking information about its
oversight of Southwest following our
investigation our priorities are always
first and foremost safety Southwest
senior director of safety management
captain Dave Hunt talked to us last
month I have the highest confidence in
their in the world
that our mechanics do and also that any
issue that's brought up any issue is
dealt with appropriately the airline is
locked in tense contract negotiations
with mechanics that have stretched on
for years
the mechanics union is expressing
concern over Southwest state of
emergency memo and its threat of
termination the memo gives the airline
the ability to assign longer work hours
and change staffing assignments the
Union worries it will increase the level
of coercion and further degrade safety
as technicians will be forced to work
mandatory overtime irrespective of
fatigue in a statement Southwest says
it's working to minimize the impact to
customers of the out of service planes
the FAA says it's closely monitoring the
situation for CBS this morning Kris Van
Cleave Washington not very comforting
for passengers when your airlines do its
operating in the state of Vermont how do
you operate an emergency I was wondering
what that means but kudos to Kris Van
Cleave for doing the story and that
clearly they're taking action but I was
flying yesterday from Charlotte to
Charlotte to here it reminds you how
much trust we put in the people we don't
know to do their jobs
oh yeah job as well so you don't want to
hear about anybody operating under
fatigue something to think about